[Music]
[Applause]
jay glazer fox nfl insider he has a new
book unbreakable how i turn my
depression and anxiety into motivation
and you can too now available online
wherever books are sold always great to
talk to jay
is ben retired right retiring from the
steelers or retiring from football do we
know yet
yeah from football okay
yeah
and well not all that they were i think
they're a little surprised he came back
this past year
so but nobody has made any he hasn't
said anything about this
why why is he holding out it's not the
steelers they know
like it's not a this wasn't uh no this
they like i said they were surprised he
came back this year and then
when he did obviously they were lucky
that he did
um but yeah there was kind of like oh
wow he's coming back all right
fantastic here we go but no yeah he's
not he's not gonna leave the steelers
and go somewhere else there was a report
i think albert breer the monday morning
quarterback that you know would the
raiders explore trading for a coach you
know they you know they do this with
with john and i said the same thing on
on fox okay
look it's the raiders right when you
have
carlos santana playing your halftime in
a preseason game
that's a rock star place right so
they are
uh i wouldn't be look i think rich
versace should be the coach like he's
it's incredible what he's done with all
the stuff that
they've had endure this season
but
yeah they i think they're looking for a
rock star to trade for a
it doesn't mean it'll happen a trade
from mike tomlin or sean payton or
something along those lines or
explore jim harbaugh somebody like that
you've got all those big whales in vegas
right so you want to make sure you want
to have a well but listen the bottom
line is you got to win and
rich versace turned this took this team
did a way better job than john gruden
did and
steered them through an awful lot like
man
people could say as much as they want
that
oh no it's not a distraction it's not
just
they have more distractions than any
team i've ever seen yeah
where does uh john gruden's lawsuit
stand
um that i don't know
anything legal i know i'm not smart
enough to really
do you know gruden
yeah yeah
but yeah but but is this
we're not boys i wouldn't say we're boys
uh no
do you think this is just a settlement
here eventually with mark davis
again that's the legal part i don't i
don't know i'm not sure
the jim harbaugh situation
um it feels like he's enjoying this
considering where he was last year at
this time where he always liked this
it's every year every year jim
harbaugh's name is connected to nfl
teams he loves this
absolutely but i will tell you this one
thing i know is that
he has talked to
other coaches
saying hey if i go back in the nfl would
you
you know would you join me would you be
interested in this so he is definitely
um
preparing for the opportunity but
i'm going to say like he does this kind
of all every year like he i think he
likes
we had to take the pay cut and then i
he may have taken michigan as far as he
could take them i mean they got blown
out by georgia people forget that
they're like yeah but they beat ohio
state i wonder if harbaugh realizes
you're never going to be better than
ohio state on a consistent basis
and then i think a lot of those guys
also they they um
there's a lot of coaches we're kind of
like you're
the way you cut like some of your
like i know when i get on my guys and
unbreakable i get on right i'm always
telling these guys no hands on your hips
neutral face we don't ever show it and i
know it wears thin on them right it
wears them out eventually i'll stop
enough so i think i like harbaugh also
like
like parcells was great with this he was
like all right my stuff lasts for three
years and then they just that's it and i
moved to the next place and i i thought
that's why college was great for jim
because he gets
everything right honestly
yeah
but in the league i think he's great
look no doubt but dude's a phenomenal
coach
right there is no
you can't contest that whatsoever and
builds winning cultures cannot contest
that whatsoever but the smart thing is
go somewhere for a few years and move on
and go somewhere else
who's the hot coaching candidate in the
nfl so it's different this year than
every other year because every other
year people want um the next
sean mcvay
and before that it was the next sean
payton
and
it's just not there this year we don't
have those hot offensive candidates and
you know this mcveigh coaching tree so
guys like dan quinn a lot of a lot of
guys that have been around like dan
quinn
uh is a hot name running around and
rightfully so right he's one and and you
want to talk about building a culture
like you can't wait to get to work every
day with dan clinton
i'll tell you this
i would say 99 of coaches change when
they get the head coaching job
and it's a very rare few that you know
and they have to change to a certain
extent
dq is the same exact dude with his
d-line coach
for the 49ers that he is today dude has
never changed he's he's a rare he's a
rare breed
if the cowboys happen to lose
this weekend
it's is
is mike mccarthy still firmly cemented
as the head coach i think he is
yeah i mean it's
i would think but i don't with the
joneses i don't know
but i would think so look here's here's
the other cowboys are a different place
who that's like this is why i say like
troy aikman's the biggest gangster of
all time because and that's why dak is
such a gangster
at position
is like
the court the head the the head coach or
quarterback um and it's with jimmy
johnson's like
incredible
those two positions are like the center
fielder for the yankees and the
shortstop for the red sox and the center
for the lakers and the point guard for
the celtics all wrapped up in one
the attention that you get right and all
the outside noise that you have to deal
with
and they get a guy there
mike mccarthy that's just gotten the
football football football i think he's
done a phenomenal job but obviously with
them that their expectations are
so incredibly high
how did the giants become this much of
an embarrassment oh my god
um
i don't think they know what they don't
know they don't know
you know even a guy like like i was i
said this weekend that joe judge
you know had
first it was like you know maybe 75
percent come back then
my pre our pregame show on fox i said 50
50 50. and by the time the ot came i was
like it's down to 25
and man there's just i think some teams
look culture is everything culture is
everything and you look at some of these
teams over and over and over who lose
like washington football team
it starts at the top and you're not
looking to go
since dan snyder took over they've never
won well maybe you guys looking top down
right detroit has never won it's you
know cleveland the one year they won
was the year that nobody else was
allowed in the building
only football
right think about that and then like i
looked what sean payton did diamond with
the saints he went down there and people
wearing bags on their heads right and
man he went down and kind of taught the
owner how to be
a winning owner and you go down to the
saints facility
man the locker room feels like a w hotel
you know they
the the weight room is like
more ridiculous than everything you've
ever seen they get this restaurant
drago's comes down and caters to them
every friday like guys don't want to
leave the facility they're there and the
giants their culture they're waiting for
the sky to fall all the time
they're just always waiting for this guy
and then
you know
yeah you know here's the issue is they
always hire from within from who they
know oh let's bring in dave gettleman
right let's go get oh joe judge is part
of belichick right they they
everybody you know they wanted that rule
because he was there for a year well you
have this culture where you're waiting
for the sky to fall
you got to go outside and build a new
culture in there and you got to build a
culture where man i cannot wait to get
to work every day and i don't want to
leave the office
talking to jay glaser fox nfl insider
his new book unbreakable how i turn my
depression and anxiety there it is
motivation and you can too
what could you that you got
is that a s medium that you got on that
that shirt there michael strahan
collection i got to give him a little
plug here it's a triple xl but thank you
for
are you body watching me right now is
that what you're doing are you body
shaming no i'm i'm i'm complimenting you
i'm envious
i mean you look swole today
[Laughter]
uh
late night last night what uh what led
you to write the book
um
my the the gray that i live and i call
it
um
you know i've talked you know someone
about this man i live in this
it's um my depression anxiety it's been
since i was it's my earliest memory
and it sucks it's a daily thing like
every single day i wake up thinking
my sky is falling and people think like
oh man you rich and famous admit like my
wallet's not an antidepressant it
doesn't work that way i
have never known how to
love myself from the inside out i don't
know what that looks like
so i've always had to use
like go do bigger things on the outside
to learn to get love
and you don't really have dudes who talk
like this and i did something a couple
years ago and i started talking and
obviously our foundation mvp emerging
vets and players like i'm an open book
there i open up and i pull my skin back
and i talk and i realize man like one of
the things that helps me be of service
but helps me get through the ready to
see the blue is being of service
and um
this book is
you know it's for all of us who live in
the gray whether you have
you know like i have whether it's
clinical you want to call it clinical
depression anxiety mental illness or or
just you just
go through hard times i wanted to be
this voice for the grave for all of us
and show us it's okay not to be okay
you we need to start talking about it
and like man
football players like they hurt their
knee they go right to the doctor or when
our heart's hurting
they don't go to doctor and this is what
we need to work on most and as
our the world has changed when this
thing came out right here
right and now all of a sudden we're
comparing ourselves to everybody else's
filtered fraction of a second in life
we think our lives suck all of a sudden
and we see so much hate online we're not
conditioned for that so i
for me to see
the blue like when i say i wake up in
the gray it's every freaking day and it
absolutely sucks it's terrible and i
never know
which version of me i'm gonna get every
day
and then when i lay my head on my pillow
at night those 15 minutes at night
the worst part of my day because i'm
laying down with someone that i don't
know how to like or love
and i just think it's a
like
not worthy of anything good
so i'm like you know what this is this
can help a lot of people
um and then recently because i did the
book
um
i started
kind of journaling
on social media
in real time
um
how it looks how living in the gray
looks
and that has
helped me cut through the gray a little
bit and see the blue see the reaction
and like man being like muscles this
this
is nothing like vulnerability is true
strength and if i could be vulnerable
with the world and especially the dudes
out there not but it's not just that
everybody i think like we all deserve to
be happy and not live in the gray and
not let that monster win and keep that
monster in the box
and it's a harder world to do that in
nowadays so that's why i wrote it i
think they came to me about it and i've
always been like no no no especially
like this but i pulled my skin back and
in the book i explained
what living the gray looks like
through a conversation that i had with
sean mcvay
we didn't really understand it
and he let me redo the conversation and
he's like wait shoot
like
you wake up every day depressed i'm like
yeah he's like why i'm like because i
have depression he's like i know thanks
but i was like
how much better of a coach you'll be
if you can understand the darkness that
leads your players to put a helmet on
and smash themselves into people over
and over and over and over or for you
and your coaches to work 20-hour days or
for somebody like me who steps in a cage
with a randy couture chuck liddell and
gets punched in my face like like we're
off we got to be off to do we do here
and you know i i i just thought it was a
great way for me to be of service to
people man and um
and i'm proud and the crazy stuff is my
gray
like i have
12 day the 25th is when it is launch
date and in my mind my world's gonna
come crashing down in the next 12 days
like i'm trying to keep it together and
not cry as i'm talking to you it's that
hard for me every day every time
something good happens
i feel so unworthy anything good ever
happened to me and
um
yeah to have this come out man where i
if
i've already had people tell me that
they were gonna
from my posts
um they were gonna turn to suicide and
because these posts they've uh here i go
they've decided to get help is uh
man that's that's why i wrote the book
well i i appreciate your friendship
because
you know i went through a
dark time
and you reached out to me
and you just said you're here you know
you were here for me so i'm right dude
never forget right
that's fine man we got like man we need
our teams and
these bonds that we have right these
brotherhoods
we can't do it alone and uh i i wanted
to make sure that you knew you had a
battle buddy who was walking this walk
with you dude and you've always been
there for me man so i i had to be there
for you
thank you jay i appreciate your time
good luck with the book thank you ma'am
that's jake glaser unbreakable how i
turn my depression and anxiety into
motivation and you can too
yeah when i
mentioned what i was going through
and i got through with that got off the
air in the first person
uh one of the first people i heard from
was jay and he said you want to talk i'm
here